what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
you know over the course of his comic
book history Thanos has done some pretty
bad things like he's done some pretty
terrible things he well I'd say one of
the greatest things he ever did was
creating the Thanos copter that was
that's actually something to be
celebrated I don't know why we haven't
seen the Thanos copter in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe yet we really need to
those you guys don't know where the
Thanos copter is the Thanos copter is is
like it's this magical thing that like
some of us can only ever hope to dream
of having but basically there was this
old super Spidey story where like Thanos
shows up on earth and he's like I'm
gonna capture the Cosmic Cube and then
there was just some crappy character the
Spider Man was hanging out with only
water nameless maybe was Hellcat I don't
know anyway Daddo slide gets the Cosmic
Cube and then like the story ends with
Thanos being arrested and taken away by
the cops but like he shows up and like a
Thanos copter and it's like okay like we
need that like like the Marvel Center
okay I'm not the only one that believes
this right like the Marvel Cinematic
Universe needs the Thanos character it's
not even a matter of want it's not even
like something I would like to see like
this is a necessity now like I want to
see Iron Man shoot down the Thanos
copter it'd be amazing but this story
here is probably the worst thing fan OHS
has ever done like of all the things
he's ever done in his whole life it's
the worst thing he's ever done it's
worse than destroying half a leg like
annihilating half the life in the
universe and Infinity Gauntlet
it's worse than destroying the
multiverse and Marvel the end it is
worse than Josh Brolin playing cable and
Thanos at the same time and betraying
the Marvel Cinematic Universe even
though he's an awesome actor and he
played it he did a really really good
job playing cable like it's worse than
these things all right it's like the
worst thing thinnest could ever do now
this comes out of Thanos annual which is
like it like it's it's just a whole
bunch of little mini stories it's like
the old anthology stories and this
story's three pages long but initially
this starts with like Thanos helping an
old lady across the street right like
there's like this little old black woman
you know like you know it's like I have
no idea what this black chicks like but
she looks like she's cool like she looks
like she makes amazing cookies right I
mean I just like okay maybe it's just me
but old people make the best food and
maybe it's because like they've been
around for so long but if I had to
choose between Jamie Oliver or like in
the 80 year old chick from Mississippi I
would choose the 80 year old chick
because it wouldn't look as pretty as
Jamie Oliver but it would taste amazing
like it were they may be the best food
you ever had in your life you would be
like Jesus awesome man like this food's
amazing Gordon Ramsay don't have
anything on this woman anyway so like he
helps this little oh this little black
lady helps her helps her across the
street because it was like there's like
the crosswalk just won't change and so
like they walk out in front of a bus
right and Dano says like everyone stop
what you're doing this little old woman
needs help crossing the street and like
he helps her and initially the bus
driver gives him some guff right the bus
drivers like hey man like what's your
problem stopping the bus and that else
is like well either I can stop the bus
truck and stop your life so which one do
you want man like leg which one he's
like you want to keep living if you want
to keep living then you gonna shut your
mouth if you want to if you don't want
to live then then you're gonna die and
that's just the way it is so like thanos
helps this helps us old lady like they
get across the other side of the street
and she's like oh you're so nice would
you like a mint and I'm surprised a nose
didn't say no no I feel like they should
be like yes I would love a breath mint
and like takes it you know and then it
breaks into like a Mentos commercial I
do I really want to see that nose on a
Mentos commercial does that be the
funniest thing yeah flash goes better
Mentos freshness fresh goes better when
Thanos is destroyed half the life for
the universe but it would be the
greatest thing like the greatest
commercial ever you know like like like
Thanos the Death Bringer like it'd be
amazing I would love that but the whole
point of this story is this chick all
right like this this this little old
woman gets helped across the street and
like everybody knows who that was he
does the whole thing under the eye of
like the Avengers no one knows he's
there but he snuck into earth and it's
like I'm going to help this old woman
across the street but the reason why is
because of like this main chick this
girl Stephanie Kircher so Stephanie
Kircher is this girl who is basically
gonna go on and like do incredible
things for the world right like the idea
is that she was basically gonna like
like eliminate inequality on on every
single level she was gonna solve world
hunger like money would become a thing
of the past she would be this person
that would basically turn earth into
like this perfect utopia um probably
Star Trek and so because of that like
like she was gonna be like this this
amazing person and so like as time
passes like she was supposed to bump
into this woman and she didn't because
the bus was delayed because Thanos
helped this old woman cross the street
and so because of the fact that she
never goes on to do these great things
she just kind of lives her life in like
the most mundane way ever you know
sitting in front of the TV probably
watching the view and like like like no
real excitement or any value in her life
whatsoever and so eventually she gets
old and she's on her deathbed and she's
essentially getting ready to die now
this is when things get brutal right
like this is this is when things get
hard court all right Thanos shows up at
this chick's deathbed like shows up and
like the moment before she dies and he
was like hello my name is Thanos and I
have come here to give you knowledge and
like in basically
shows her like here's all the great
things you were supposed to do you were
supposed to bring about world peace and
you were supposed to you know like do
things that were cool you know and like
you know these these things that matter
and are nice you know all the stuff
Millennials want you to do but you're
gonna do all these amazing things in the
world is gonna be a utopia but you
didn't and you didn't because I knew you
would do that and I wanted to make Earth
worse so I delayed the bus so that you
would not bump into that chick and earth
would be worse off than it is now so
like know that you could have done
incredible things with your life but you
didn't because I got in your way and
it's like it's this like the crazy dudes
the crappiest thing ever
right it's the meanest thing ever at
least when Thanos destroyed half the
life in the universe with the Infinity
Gauntlet
he was like indiscriminate right he's
just like half life of the universe gone
not even picking and choosing you know I
mean Marvel kind of picked and choose by
getting rid of like the the least
popular characters but it's like you
know like hey like half the life in the
universe is gone now and that's it you
know that's just the way it is you know
like in in Marvel the end when he got
the heart of the universe the single
most powerful artifact in the history of
existence which basically made him equal
to the one above all he destroyed the
entirety of the multiverse in order to
fix it so when he set everything back
because Adam warlock convinced him to he
was like okay everything's back to
normal now except nobody dies of course
Marvel said that's not really in
continuity because if no one can die
then it means stories become hard to
write and if stories become hard to
write it means Marvel cannot
assembly-line them and over saturate the
market with sixty counting books a month
so because of all this like it gets
crazy like it gets nuts you know but
Thanos always did things for like the
greater good right I mean in a lot of
ways it was for the greater good I mean
I don't really know how annihilating
half the life in the universe was for
the greater good um but we can just kind
of say it was because the movie said it
was so whatever what like like usually
he does things for like a particular
purpose to go towards like a much
grander scheme this wasn't for that it
was just like making out like just
making him this woman miserable like on
her deathbed just being like you never
achieved anything of note because I kept
you from doing it and it's just like
damn that's like that's like that's like
running up on a person in a thunderstorm
and just like snatching their umbrella
and just being haha I took your umbrella
and now you will get rain on you like
it's just it's just like the meanest
thing that you could do it's just it's
it's brutal man it's hardcore man but
like I think this is like the meanest
thing that hos has ever done I just mean
what is it's just mean
it's something like violent it's not
even like like on a universal level it
sound like Thanos wins where he goes to
the future fights God Hulk in his future
so it's not even like that
like it's just like it's just like where
he's just like just targets a chick and
it's just like I'm going to make your
life meaningless because you will do
good things and that's bad like like
damn son like it's just cold-blooded
it's just cold-blooded it's just all
this is it's the most cold-blooded thing
I've ever seen but let me know what you
guys think down in the comments section
I'm kind of curious because I feel like
this is brutal man like like the meanest
thing like the worst thing that has ever
done that's not gonna call this the
worst thing that has ever done because I
feel like this is but I feel like a lot
of you guys will agree with me too right
like I feel like a lot of you guys will
agree this is the worst thing that
Thanos has ever done in the history of
the Marvel Universe like it's it's
messed up like it's it's pretty brutal
and pretty cold-blooded but with that
being said if you guys are new here to
comments explain it make sure you guys
have the sub button to become part of
the Rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like also I
want to provide a little bit of a bumper
here at the end um for those of you guys
who don't know I currently have a
patreon page on allow many of you guys
are really interested in that it's by no
means a requirement it's just kind of a
thing that's there but that is the place
where I basically give Rob four rings
away if you're interested in having one
check out the patreon link down in the
description and and and yeah I mean
again it's not really a requirement like
I do not feel like you have to
contribute to it I certainly don't want
to make that impression on you guys I
mean I really have it there more because
of the fact that YouTube is really
really unstable at the moment because
YouTube's so unpredictable and you don't
really know what direction is gonna go
in I mean there Dee monetizing channels
left and right they're really kind of
destroying their own platform they're
hoping they survive with YouTube TV but
like nobody cares about YouTube TV
because nobody cares about cable
television maybe it'll succeed who knows
but like but like let me know you know
just feel free to I mean you don't have
to do it ya know I mean I just want to
reiterate that point because I feel like
people kind of have a habit of saying
like patreon like oh you're selfish you
know but it's not really like that it's
just kind of a back up there in case you
tube tanks so that you know my channel
and the content I create can basically
continue on with that thing you said
guys we're go ahead bring this video to
an end if you are new here to comment
explain it make sure you guys have the
sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]